so not only can a magnetic field
exert some force on a moving charge
we're now going to learn that a moving
charge or a current can actually create
a magnetic field so
there is some type of symmetry here and
as we'll learn later when we learn our
our calculus and and we do this in a
slightly more uh
rigorous way uh we'll see that
electro
that magnetic fields and electric fields
are actually two sides of the same coin
of of really electromagnetic fields but
anyway we won't worry about that now and
i think it's it's enough to ponder right
now that a current can actually induce
a magnetic field and actually just a
moving electron creates a magnetic field
and it does it in a kind of a surface of
a sphere i won't go into all of that
right now because that gets the math
gets a little bit fancy there but what
you might encounter in your your
standard high school physics class
that's not getting deeply into vector
calculus is that if you just have a
wire
let me draw a wire
that's my wire
and it's carrying some current i
it's carrying some current i
it turns out that this wire will
generate a magnetic field and the shape
of that magnetic field is going to be
concentric circles around this
around this wire and let me see if i can
draw that
so here i'll draw it just like how i do
when i try to do rotations of solids in
the calculus
video so the magnetic field it would go
behind
and in front
and it goes
like that
or another way you could think about it
is if let's go down here is on the left
side of this wire if you say that the
wire is in the plane of this video
the magnetic field is popping out
of your screen
it's popping out of the screen and on
this side on the right side the magnetic
field is popping into the screen
it's going into the screen
right and you can imagine that right
this you could imagine if on this
drawing up here
you could say this is where it
intersects the screen all of this is
kind of behind the screen
and all of this is in front of the
screen and this is where it's popping
out
and this is where it's popping into the
screen hopefully that makes a little bit
sense and how did i know that it's
rotating this way
well it actually does come out of the
cross product when you do it with a
regular charge and and all of that but
we're not going to go into that right
now and so there's a different right
hand rule that you can use and it's
literally you hold this
wire or you imagine holding this wire
with your right hand with your thumb
going in the direction of the current
and if you hold this wire with your
thumb going into the direction of the
current your fingers are going to go in
the direction
of the magnetic field so let me see if i
can draw that
i will draw it in blue
so
if this is my thumb
my thumb is going along the top of the
wire
and then my hand is curling around the
wire
right those are my knuckles
those are the veins on my hand
this is my
nail
so as you can see if this was if i was
holding that same wire
let me draw the wire so if i was holding
that same wire
we see that my thumb is going in the
direction of the current so this is a
slightly new thing to memorize
and what is the magnetic field doing
what's going in this in the direction of
my fingers right my fingers are popping
out on this side of the wire right
they're coming out on this side of the
wire and they're going in or at least my
hand is going in on that side so
it's popping it's going into the screen
hopefully that makes sense
now how can we quantify well before we
quantify let's get a little bit more of
the intuition of what's happening it
turns out that the closer you get to the
wire the stronger the magnetic field and
the further you get out the weaker the
magnetic field and that kind of makes
sense if you kind of uh imagine the
magnetic field spreading out
you know
well yeah i don't want to go into too
sophisticated analogies but if you
imagine the magnetic field spreading out
as it goes further and further out it
kind of gets distributed over a wider
and wider circumference and actually the
formula i'm going to give you kind of
has a taste for that
so the formula for the magnetic field
and it really is defined with a with a
cross product and things like that but
for our purposes
we won't worry about that you'll just
have to know kind of that this is the
shape
if the current is going in that
direction and of course if the current
was going downwards then the magnetic
field would just reverse direction there
would still be in concentric circles
around the wire but anyway what is the
magnet the magnitude of that field
it is
the magnitude
of that magnetic field
is equal to
mu
which is a greek letter which i will
explain in a second
times the current
divided by
2 pi r so this has a little bit of a of
a feel for what i was saying before that
the further you go out where r is how
far you are from the wire
right the further you go out if r gets
bigger the magnitude of the magnetic
field is going to get weaker and this 2
pi r that looks a lot like the
circumference of a circle so that gives
you a taste for it i know i haven't
proved anything uh
rigorously but it at least gives you a
sense oh look there's a little formula
for circumference of a circle here and
that kind of makes sense right because
the magnetic field at that point is kind
of a circle it's the the magnitude is
equal at an equal radius around that
wire now what is this mu this thing that
looks like a u well that's the
permeability of the material that the
wire is in so the magnetic field is
actually going to have a different
strength depending on whether this wire
is going through
rubber whether it's going through a
vacuum or air or metal or water
and for the purposes of your high school
physics class we assume that it's going
through air normally and the value for
air
is pretty close to the value for a
vacuum and it's called the permeability
of a vacuum and i forget what that value
is i could look it up but it actually
turns out that your your calculator has
that value so let's do a problem just to
put some numbers to the formula so let's
say i had this current
and it is
it is i don't know the the current is
equal to i'm going to make up a number 2
amperes
2 amperes and let's say that i am
that i just pick a point
right here
that is
let's say that that's three meters
away from the wire in question so my
question to you is what is the magnitude
in the direction of the magnetic field
right there
well the magnitude is easy we just
substitute in this equation so the
magnitude of the magnetic field
at this point
is equal to the per and we assume that
the wire is going through air or vacuum
the permeability of free space that's
just a constant all that looks fancy
times the current times 2 amperes
divided by 2 pi r what's r it's 3 meters
so 2 pi times 3 so it equals
permeability of free space so let's see
the 2 and the 2 cancel out over
three pi so how do we calculate that
well we we get out our our trusty ti 85
calculator
and i think you'll you'll be
maybe pleasantly surprised or or shocked
to realize that i deleted everything
just so you can see how i get there that
it actually has the permeability of free
space stored in it so what you do is you
go to second and you press constant
which is the four button
they say the built-in constants
and let's see it's not one of those you
press more
it's not one of those you press more oh
look at that
mu naught the permeability of free space
that's what i need
and i have to divide it by 3 pi
divided by
3
and then where is pi there it is it's
over the
power sign divided by 3 pi
it equals 1.3 times 10 to the negative
seventh that's going to be tesla's the
magnetic field
is going to be equal to 1.3 times 10 to
the minus seventh teslas
so it's a fairly a fairly weak magnetic
field and that's why you don't have
metal objects being thrown around by the
wires uh behind your your television set
but anyway hopefully that gives you a
little bit and you know just just so you
know just how it all fits together so we
we we're saying that a a
these moving charges not only can they
be affected by a magnet field not only
can a current be affected by a magnetic
field or just a moving charge it
actually creates them
and that that kind of creates a little
bit of symmetry in your head hopefully
because if that was also true of
electric field a charge a stationary
charge is
obviously pulled or pushed by a static
electric field and it also creates its
own static electric field so it's always
in the back of your mind because if you
keep studying physics you're going to
actually
prove to yourself that electric and
magnetic fields are two sides of of the
same coin and it just looks like a
magnetic field when you're in a
different frame of reference when
something is whizzing past you while if
you're whizzing along with it then that
thing would look static and then it
would might look a little bit more like
an electric field but anyway i'll i'll
leave you there now and uh in the next
video i will show you what happens when
we have two
wires
carrying current
parallel to each other and and you might
guess that they might actually attract
or repel each other anyway i'll see you
in the next video